foreign
[Music]
who are we
where did we come from
how did we come to be
these are questions that human beings
have asked since we acquired the
facility to ask questions and across
Millennia text both secular and sacred
have recorded our various Journeys in
search of answers
Century those Journeys took a sharp turn
as Thomas Henry Huxley leveraged
Darwin's theory of evolution to argue
that if new species of animals could
evolve from earlier species than so
could humans
a new discipline emerged paleo
empropology the scientific study of
human Origins combining insights from
archeology anthropology and the fossil
record which throughout the 20th century
convincingly demonstrated that human
beings did indeed evolve from earlier
ancestors
more recently analyzes of the human
genome have further revolutionized our
understanding of human Origins
there is now strong evidence that our
species Homo sapiens shared planet Earth
with a number of other species of early
humans and that we all got along fairly
friendly as many of us carry DNA from
some of those species
so what set us apart from those other
human species and why did we Prevail
perhaps our ability to think abstractly
made the difference we create art for
pleasure we use symbols to communicate
information and ideas we develop rituals
that create cohesion and identity within
a community and that level of abstract
reasoning is a profound part of what
defines us that's what makes us human
but new research is challenging this
perspective by raising the tantalizing
possibility that we may not be as
different as we once thought because
some of the other early human species
may have also had creative and Abstract
faculties findings that may well be
rewriting the story of humankind
[Music]
foreign
thank you
you know when we try to answer some of
those questions questions that really
speak to who we are how we fit in to a
grand story a grand narrative
issues of origin prove to be these
powerful anchors of our understanding at
least in part that's why many of us are
consumed with trying to understand the
Big Bang the origin of the universe the
origin of it all we are driven to
understand the origin of galaxies and
stars and planets we want to know the
origin of life we want to know where
intelligence comes from
and as we pass through the lineages we
want to know where our genus came from
where our species
has come from and this is a journey as
briefly noted in that piece that we have
vigorously pursued for some time and our
guest here today is one of the leading
Lights of the field Our Guest is Lee
Berger a name who many of you are deeply
familiar with who has made some of the
real great discoveries in trying to
further our understanding of those deep
questions he is the chair of the Paleo
anthropology department
at the University of it waters run in
Johannesburg South Africa he has had
wonderful series on National Geographic
Nova and he is here today to
give us a sense of where we are in this
Grand Quest and the wonderful thing
about Lee is not only is he one of the
Prime movers in our evolving
understanding of our own Evolution he's
also
one of the great narrators of science
one of the great storytellers that
speaks to this journey that we humans
have been on to try to understand
ourselves and so it really does give me
great pleasure to Welcome to the stage
Lee Berger
thank you thank you everyone thank you
Brian thank you
all right so in our our discussion today
it'd be great to
get caught up on the rapidly moving
field of understanding human Origins but
before we get to that particular story
which speaks to all of us if you don't
mind I'd like to spend a little bit time
on your individual story because look I
mean part of the reason we have these
conversations is you know you want to
inspire the Next Generation so that they
can get a sense of you know what it
takes to be somebody who really changes
our understanding in the way that you
and your colleagues have so
very beginning you you you're you were
born in in Georgia is that correct I was
born I wasn't born in Georgia I was born
in Kansas
Georgia is sort of the rural South and
hillow Brisbane it's great to be here
I I was a kid that grew up in sort of
this idyllic rural area you know I would
spend my Summers fishing and running
through the woods and like Dorothy like
without the dress mostly yeah and I
would
that was fascinating as a child with you
know Native American artifacts which
appear from plowed fields and geology my
my grandfather was a uh a frustrated oil
Wildcatter you know one of those guys
missing fingers from the chains and you
know had pet chimpanzees and drove a
Cadillac and my father grew up in the
back of a slipstream trailer in the
Texas and Oklahoma regions and
um so there was this deep Fascination
but that wasn't the pathway they ended
up they were middle class family my
mother was a math teacher my father sold
real estate insurance and I was a bright
kid in a rural community and in that
time there was kind of only a few places
that a bright kid could go like that and
and I think it's probably a lot like
rural areas everywhere in the world you
were going to be a doctor a lawyer an
engineer an accountant and maybe
particular to the south of America a
preacher and one of those would become a
politician sometime or something like
that
um so I would you know I had to give a
scholarship I got Naval scholarship went
to
University at pre-law
um and hated every moment really
except I got to take electives
I got to take electives in geology and
Archeology and for the first time in my
life which I really didn't even Envision
those as a career
you know they weren't in front of me as
a way to a pathway I saw people who
absolutely adored what they did I also
found out that all that time spent
exploring as a kid was valuable in
finding fossils I had a knack for it I
could go with a field trip and see the
fossils they were looking for and find
them and
I I became one of these funny things of
of failing all my main courses literally
F's and D's you know on that is that
really true that's true and making
Straight A's in all my electives
and I ended up in front of this naval
officer you know he was my academic
officer and one of the horrible things
was at that time if you'd accepted one
of these officer scholarships you'd have
to pay is that really true pay it back
if you fail out
and you go enlisted to do that in
Vanderbilt where I was very expensive
school it's been many many years in the
Navy and so I'm standing there at
attention you got to imagine this you
know I'm in my you know these sort of
Top Gun whites standing there at
attention in front of this officer
that's my life in his hands my attention
and he's he's got this paper on his desk
which is my transcript which is
embarrassing because there's lots of fs
and D's on it you know and he says
Burger
Lieutenant Ron strikes by the way Naval
aviator and he said Burger he says what
do you see here and he pushes it across
with one finger and I remember going
something like you know failure sir you
know something dramatic like that
he said I don't see that
he says I see a young man and hasn't
found what he loves
he said if you promise me this you will
quit the university right now
go find what you love and then come back
and he pointed to the geology and
archeology
I'll let you out I'll sign your release
papers with Noah that's hugely unusual
boy you know it was he had it
particularly for a naval officer yeah
and I said yes and went and found myself
and eventually came back to University
and it was never work for a second after
that you know I'd found this place
and that took me on this journey that I
was gonna you know I came back and of
course I I found paleontology like one
does and I find dinosaur paleontology
like every young person does and I was
going to be a dinosaur paleontologist
and I read a book called Lucy sure my
Dawn Johansson I'm sure many people have
read that
and in that and in the discussions that
were occurring around that Don had said
that there's something like a one in 10
million chance of Discovery in an
ancient human relative fossil even if
you are in an area where they are known
to be
and it's in Africa
and for some reason that had incredible
attractiveness and resonance man maybe I
shouldn't be proud of that and maybe I
shouldn't even reflect that but it it
had you know I was thinking here's a
field
that even if you make a tiny Discovery
you can change I mean at that time it's
hard for people I think to imagine at
that time in history
there were almost certainly more people
who studied human Origins and evolution
than there were physical objects they
studied
imagine that imagine a field of science
that has more practitioners than it does
data
it does not make for a pretty field of
science I assure you it makes for a very
violent possessive
scare science that that and and
paleoanthropology was every bit of that
in the in the late 80s and early enough
but there's something really interesting
there so you were driven more by The
Challenge than necessarily the specific
content I mean if it was one in 10
million to find you know a bone of you
know a a giraffe or of some ancient sort
that might have been the direction that
you went absolutely I think to be honest
I mean
who isn't interested in human Origins
right who is an interest in where you
come from same reason I bet everyone in
this audience has has looked at their
genealogy you ever wondered why you do
that you do that because you understand
that you're in your grandparents great
grandparents Those Distant lineages
there is meaning and the making of you
yeah
I just do that people like me just do
that in the extreme we're interested in
the making of us
and so I of course I'm attracted to that
it had meaning to me but yeah you know I
was up for that challenge I buy lottery
tickets too but is that the case I mean
I was going to ask you are you I mean
Lottery is not much of a risk because
there's not much to lose there but are
you a risk taker I I am I am I think
you'll hear a little bit about that as
we go on but I'm not a gambler by the
way but I do buy a lottery ticket just
because the story of my life has been
sort of Lottery level discoveries but
you know you guaranteed if you play the
lottery enough that you will lose all
your money it's virtually guaranteed
you're also guaranteed that I just don't
find it that interesting you're also
guaranteed that if you don't buy a
lottery ticket true too you will never
win that's true too but that suggests
you should buy one ticket because you go
from zero odds to infinitely more at all
which is still a tiny number but still
yeah okay anyway so we won't fixate on
um
and so you decide to go in that
direction what's your next to get to
Africa you know this is a closed field
and so I ended up making a phone call
back in the days when you had to look up
phone numbers and a phone book or call
an operator found Don Johansson's number
in California and I heard he was coming
to talk to the Georgia science Teachers
Association I called him up got his
Bulldog of his secretary I mispronounced
his name you know the fact Dr Johansson
in she said Johansson you know I was
almost in and then got through to him
amazing when he took my call and I said
you know I live in Georgia I'd like to
meet you and we did they took a liking
to me and he heard my story
and I'd had by then a degree I was in
geology and a degree in archeology and
anthropology
he said you know what I need an
assistant going to hold of I Gorge where
I'm going to work and uh
you can be that assistant this summer
I'm made right my life's about to happen
go away Scrabble together get money for
a a plane ticket I'm on my way in that
direction and I get three weeks before
he's going he calls up and say he lost
his permit he's not going
and he did something really strange
there which I've you know I I I've
inquired but I never got a really
truthful explanation to he took the
moment to call Richard Leakey which some
of you will hear from the great leaky
family of Kenya who he knew is holding
the Harvard University kubi for field
school at the same time and he said
there's this young guy and he I've
disappointed him we're not going
now a lot of people don't know this Don
and Richard really didn't like each
other very much
they were at war with each other it's
two of the biggest Fossil Finders of
that time for some reason Richard said
sure he can come
and I went and I found myself in Africa
where in Africa uh it could be four
Northern Kenya Lake turkana Jade C
and on the first day there we arrived at
the day before after this just two-day
you know Lorry Journey and we get there
and I am so excited I cannot sleep I get
up at four in the morning I'm the only
one up except there's a light at this
this tea tent that they have and I
walked over there and there I met John
Kim and get you was preparing to go out
for the day one of Richard's great
Fossil Finders he looks at me and you
know he sees this enthusiastic kid awake
at 4 30 in the morning he said you want
to come with me
I'm like yeah yeah I do
go out and next magical six or seven
hours was just where he taught me to see
this landscape and see the fossils and
understand it
and I'm enthralled I have found this
thing and on the way back eleven o'clock
it it gets hotter than here in Brisbane
by the way so you know you know it's
terrible
and we're walking back 11 o'clock in the
morning 100 meters from the uh the Land
Rover and I looked down and there's a
piece of a femur of a hominid on the
ground
pick it up first day in Africa first day
on the fossil Fields beat the odds
so that was one in 10 million right I
don't know I don't know if that number's
true yeah no no we'll talk about that
poetically poetically yeah it was one in
10 million man I was hooked you couldn't
have dragged me out of Africa ended up I
had applied to phds that's the working
degree in this field as you know and I
all over the world got into most of the
places but I was waiting on I'd gone to
Richard then and and Don for advice
because I said you know I want to be a
Fossil Finder and they said you're not
working in East Africa they said that to
me just like that meaning no place for a
young American guy in that landscape
they were too young they were too
violent it was all you know partitioned
out
and both of them gave me the same advice
they said go to South Africa this was
you got to remember the context of this
this is late 1989.
they just announced that Mandela was
going to be released in February of
1990. and they said you know the
Landscapes may be changing they heard
that a fellow named Philip Tobias one of
the great professors of this field had a
vault full of fossils they've been
discovered over the last you know 30 40
years but hadn't been described really
because of the apartheid government's
repression so it's a vault in South
Africa in South Africa the University of
water surround
and I had applied there
and so I called from a ticket but hadn't
heard from them so I called from a tiki
box for those of you don't know what
that is it's a it was a pay phone you
put the little you know Shillings in and
you know he answers on the other side
with oh dear boy you know when are you
arriving that was my acceptance letter
to the University of the waters room
and so that's where I went and
it was crazy time you can imagine uh
1990 there is Mendoza was released in
places well you know but I threw myself
into walking the high felt of that area
and as I was coming out of this East
African mentality of 1 in 10 million
yeah
there hadn't been a hominid Discovery at
a new site
in sub-equatorial Africa since
1947 48 not nothing nothing not an East
Side there's a lot you know there's a
government yeah right a little thing
like that right it said you know they
didn't particularly like the idea of
people searching for the idea of the
commonality of all humankind and those
other the subject wasn't particularly
popular
um and but I was looking for a site that
had a lot of Bones
and found one
John called gladysville
so I I was given a job by the way way
out of my league as a table doctor
teaching Anatomy I never taught anatomy
in my life but I read well and you're
still a doctoral student now yeah a
doctoral student and the and then I was
teaching this BSC course in an honors
course in science which I was teaching
the human Origins component of it you
can all tell how highly qualified I was
for this is the first courses I'd ever
taught him in that and
um and I so I enlisted them I drafted
them as part of the course to come out
and work for me at gladysville
um under the argument that that's how
you learn you know it's practical it was
a former slave labor I know but don't
tell anyone
and 16 days into this first expedition
like Michelle Erasmus young women on
this course picked up a rock and turned
it over and handed me and said is that a
tooth they're sticking out this rock is
hominid there it is a hominid tooth
that's one on the left was the first one
the next morning the second one comes
out two teeth you guys go really you
know I can see them you can hear the you
know the the awe in the audience right
two teeth
those two teeth got me in National
Geographic magazine
that is that and you know and then I
threw myself into this site
there I am throwing myself into this
site I knew that the next Rock I would
turn over
would have that half of a mandible of a
hominid in it because I mean two teeth
in 16 days
and I could dine on that at conferences
for the rest of my life
because at that time in history you
could
because there's so little that already
nothing existed yeah
and
it did not happen at least not for the
first week
how about the first 17 years yeah
don't go too oh it's not that bad I was
having a great career I was doing all
the things a scientist does I you know I
had discoveries I I had devised an idea
that the tong child a Famous Fossil was
killed by a bird of prey that started a
whole scientific Endeavor itself very
proud of I was one of the first
scientists very controversial say that
early australopithesis means the most
primitive of the eight men so to speak
had long arms and short legs when we
thought they were all human proportioned
which got me in a lot of trouble in the
in the 1990s but I didn't have that
discovery
and by the end of the 1990s just on the
verge of the 21st century I'd risen to
this position I took over Philip
tobias's chair he'd retired I was a kid
though and you know I began to hear
these International conferences here I
am in charge of all of this now you know
I've never seen someone go so far on two
teeth
and you know while I was naive I wasn't
naive enough to know that was not a
compliment that was a sort of uh you
know they this field was possessive and
it was about a mythology built around
the discoverers you almost had to be
touched by God if that's not too much to
discover these things particular and
then it began you know not just these
things but good ones
you know they started putting a level on
it
and I went through the worst years of my
life in the early 21st century it was
terrible because
I was becoming the poster child for the
idea that that the Age of Exploration
was dead
that there were no new fossil fields to
discover there was even paper published
in 2001 by the biggest Fossil Finder of
that period you know who I'm talking
about who said There will not be any new
discoveries that change the way we
understand human evolution
that there will be no new fossil Fields
found
and that we should stop training people
to be young paleoanthropologists because
it is insanity to have a field where
there are more people studying this than
there are objects they study that
kill funding for exploration I mean
killed it dead and that's a fairly
common kind of Rhythm right in the late
1890s there was a statement in physics
that all the fundamental laws have been
discovered and All That Remains is to
determine this or that constant of
nature to the sixth decimal place and
then we have special relativity general
relativity and quantum mechanics so I
suspect you did not take that as the
final word on it hurt my wallet yeah my
ability to do exports but you're right I
mean I knew the history of dinosaur
paleontology same thing early 19th
century we have it all of course we
didn't
but it was tough
um I'll tell you how tough it was that
my University convinced by the external
forces of these big discoveries of
fossils said you know what we're going
to close your exploration unit
this is now 2006 2007.
and we're going to hire under the
convincing of these outside forces
University a young person to come in and
revolutionize it because the idea was
what was getting on the covers of Nature
and Science were the where the sort of
Imaging the the sort of new technologies
that were being applied to fossils so
the existing ones just analyzing we were
never going to find more
and I found myself in this really weird
thing I hope none of you ever do in your
entire lives of of actually sitting on a
committee to replace myself
I was like 40 years old
in a 40 little old where you resigned to
this being the end of this career
Channel or I was soul-searching
and I ended up I remember the day this
all happened next part of the story
I was seen at home on my computer
and I was doing what I guess old people
of Our Generation do when you're
absolutely have no idea what your future
direction is I was Googling my future
you know just trolling the internet
saying you know what is a guy who's
dedicated game the poster boy of of of
failure and exploration what am I going
to do next and at that moment
I became the singular last human being I
am convinced on Earth to discover Google
Earth
and
I the reason it is so stupid is I have
been a pioneer as you know Brian in the
90s I'm trying to take technology
handheld GPS satellite images and
combine them into a way to make
discoveries I was convinced there was
something there but
the satellite images cost ten thousand
dollars a sheet the pixelation was
terrible the handheld GPS's were
terrible and expensive and I had failed
at that I had I'd run a three-year
National Geographic funded expedition to
do it and hadn't really done much at all
and um but then I'm sitting here looking
at Google Earth I I noticed that little
white box up the corner for GPS
coordinates and I had like some of the
most expensively obtained GPS
coordinates ever and I put it in and
does this right it doesn't zoom into
thing and I started
I of course looked if I was you know I
looked at my house first I'll admit that
see if you're naked by the pool you know
that kind of thing and I wasn't and then
and then I applied it to these sites and
that it didn't land on the sides that
I'd met in the 90s and it didn't take me
long to Google why it didn't because the
U.S government had owned the satellites
at that time and put deliberate air into
them so they couldn't use for terrorism
and that sort of thing and so that with
the the sort of uh era that was in the
handheld GPS is create a compounding air
I would devastate I mean I'd spent I'd
wasted three years of my life I'd
publish some of that data wasted in the
sense that you thought you were looking
in one area when it was actually
displaced from where I thought I was
mapping things and wasn't mapping things
I was mapping nonsense hmm
that's not good it's not great for your
scientific reputation to be you know
publishing that kind of nonsense but I
quickly learned that I could see the
sites
on Google Earth that I intended to and I
started moving those dots from the wrong
place to the right place you could see
them through features in the landscape
you'll see like you'll see some right
there like you see those trees see those
little clusters of trees that's the
green dots yeah
those clusters of trees are marking cave
sites and fossil sites there were about
103 known at that point and I started
looking and started saying wow
if that's a cave site then that looks
like a cave site
and so out I went to ground truth them
out walking in this sort of environment
to see whether these were actually I
knew they couldn't this was the most
explored area on planet Earth for these
things there's no way they were
and as I started exploring on the very
first day out I created this target map
if you can imagine
printed it out as far away from
gladysville as I could get because I you
know at 17 years of failure in that spot
I knew it better than anyone else I went
all the way 30 kilometers away to the
edge of these dolomitic limestones
the greatest potential for these
and on the first day found over 20 new
sites went for 103 to 123 one day
I was blown away I mean we'd missed it
all right in front of us you know and
what they look like where you know they
were these clusters of trees by sight
you mean new caves caves and some fossil
sites so there were only let me put that
in perspective there were only 17 known
fossil sites I'd found four of them back
in that 1990 Expedition and then all of
a sudden
there are more of them and I started
going out every day over and over again
one after the other one after the other
and suddenly every day I was building
this map
January February March April May June
July by then I found over
750 new sites in the most explored area
on planet Earth I was like oh my god
this is my contribution this is what I
will leave the future this almost
unlimited potential of Discovery and was
it mostly tree clumps as the operative
way I'm sure we have an image of tree
clumps that's what they look like
everyone's excited I can hear the you
know the awe in the audience
but in that treatment white wild olives
white stink Woods clustered together you
could see them from space
and in those are are often depressions
holes in the ground sometimes fossils
that have been mined off and they were
mining for lime in that area back in the
you know late 1900s early 20th century
and
um eventually I had moved right back
into the area of gladysville
and I knew there was nothing there to
find but I'd gone after a couple of
these tree clumps and walked up to
actually this one
and went to it first in the first rock I
turned over had a fossil in it which
surprised me because this thing is like
800 meters from where I'd spent 17 years
working
and I'd miss these fossils
I felt like an idiot
but I was fossil hunting that day I in
cave hunting that day so I just you know
took the maps down and then went up
anything and found 47 new sites in this
one Valley right next to the valley I'd
been in for 17 years unsuccessfully
uh it bugged me a little bit
um
yeah yeah I had that reaction too
a tragedy had occurred a couple of weeks
before which I hadn't told you about and
that is the young man that was going to
take over we'd selected to bring in this
new technology and stuff I lived in the
UK and was killed in a motorcycle
accident
and we had already hired all the young
postdocs bought the equipment and stuff
and so one of them a couple of days
later came into my office job Kibby and
he was a postdoc and he said would I be
a supervisor
and don't call me heartless I said no
you know you're a lab guy I'm a field
guy
and then I thought about it Mom I said
but you know I just found this site
I've just found this cluster of trees
and it's bugging the heck out of me
why I missed this and so if you want to
take another look at it with me maybe
I'll teach you to be a Fossil Finder and
so
off we went August 15 2008.
job myself with a nine-year-old son
Matthew my dog Tau we arrived there in
that beautiful Wilderness Area and I I
take them up and tell them how we found
a you know a much shorter version of
what I just told you walk up to the site
and I say okay there's this little hole
in the ground go find fossils if you
find one call me I'll identify it let's
see what this site has to offer and with
that Tau and Matthew are gone you know
they they raced off and and you know
they're leopards and giraffe and stuff
and I think they're going to chase those
and they'll see them at lunchtime and so
I'm standing there that's not funny
[Laughter]
and and
I'm standing there telling job you know
the miners found it but they didn't put
much glass and Matthew goes off and he
says Dad I found a fossil he calls me 15
years off and I start walking towards
him that's actually what I saw this
picture taken at the moment it's only
this little clump of Rock
and five meters away I knew his in my
life were about to change forever
because inside of that rock I could see
something that would look innocuous to
you that
heard the audience go wow
I went wow
um because that was a hominid clavicle
and at that moment in history I was
probably one of the world's only experts
on hominy clavicles I'd done my PhD on
that bone
all six or seven of them had been found
to date from that time I knew it exactly
it'll sign
Matthew said I cursed I don't believe
that I turned that rock over and on the
back of it was part of a mandible in the
rest of the skeleton coming out of that
block Matthew found a partial skeleton
of a hominid one of the rarest things in
all of history there were literally
probably seven or so Lucy turkana boy
one he would hear of
and that was it and he just found one
and that was lying on the surface lying
on Surface no idea why
in that rock
and that would lead to the discovery of
a new species that that you'll see I
mean beautiful skulls things like that
all in the area right around there
that's right in the Rock they have to be
prepared out you know skulls or they're
just beautifully complete from an
australopatika sediba we would
eventually call it a two million year
old hominid things like this we had
never seen things like that in the
fossil record and as we would prepare
these blocks out by the way that takes
about 22
000 person hours to get to that state
from its concrete like things we would
eventually find skeletons first time in
history two skeletons had been found
together at the same deposit
and suddenly my life changed yeah
you know I went from the guy who was
making a career off two teeth
to
this one of the richest fossil sites
ever discovered in Africa we named a new
species Australopithecus sediva got on
the cover of science well done you ever
been on the cover of science not yet
three times
that's right you know people understand
you know being on sign for nature for us
are fossils not us it's like for Rock
Star being on the cover of Rolling Stone
magazine well I have done that oh yeah
oh congratulations and you'd always live
in the dream my project Grew From one
scientist to 40 to 100 and 100 plus in a
matter of months and then a year
paper after paper in the highest Journal
I was applying technology I mean we had
the coolest stuff we were taking
synchrotron highest energy light sources
in the world and we were turning them
into these mobile objects that we were
doing we were able to create and
reconstruct these just amazing uh things
by using it was the perfect time the
perfect moment
to make discoveries you know computers
had come along you could image stuff I
got to apply Open Access models to it
and I got to bring in early career
scientists and other people which was
just believe it or not anathema tour and
open access was rare yeah not only in
science in general but in your field in
particular which was fairly hold on to
your results well it was a field of
scarcity you know you didn't find these
things and that was it and you know time
went by two three four years
and then we I started building this
laboratory because we found things like
Organics over uh in malapa which by the
name of the site I named malapa or my
home in the sutu language
and I
I started building this laboratory and
suddenly got locked out of the site and
realized I hadn't been exploring you
know I hadn't I hadn't bought that
lottery ticket you know and contrary to
what you say you know in my field
exploration is the buying of the lottery
ticket if you're not exploring you're
not going to make the discoveries
and it was and so I was thinking well
you know what am I going to do while I'm
locked out of this site I got this big
team ready and that and I remember that
map that I created back in 2008 we're
now all the way up in 2013.
and
at that moment
a former student of mine Pedro boshoff
walks through the door
he's bankrupt barefoot in tears he'd
lost everything
and playing the lottery you know well
kind of he went to diamond mining in
West Africa but that's as close to that
as you you can get and The Coincidence
of that was I was beginning to think
about what I could do with that map I
created of you know now eight or nine
hundred localities
um that I'd stop doing the moment Matt
said dad I found a fossil
and I was thinking you know because one
of the interesting things is they're not
just on the surface every one of those
points is potentially a doorway into the
underworld
into these spaces beneath the ground
these labyrinths of cave spaces that cut
through that area hundreds of kilometers
of them but no one explored them at the
time the general sense was there wasn't
going to be a fine to be made that's
right underground because the idea was
that the the older caves were on the
surface because the grounds eroding away
so the older stuff's on the surface and
the caves underground are actually the
newer caves
and so The Coincidence of all that and
the Serendipity of all that was that
Pedro was my cating buddy back in the
90s
and so I said okay you know
let's go look at these let's use my map
and go underground but what I want you
to do is to actually you know use these
sites to to to go to the places we think
we know best first
because I learned a little bit from
gladysville you know things in your own
backyard might be the places and so off
he went he came back very quickly said
he wasn't physiologically appropriate to
get into many of the caves he was too
fat
um
and so we very reluctantly or I very
reluctantly enlisted with him to amateur
cavers Steve Tucker and Rick Hunter who
were physiologically appropriate for
getting into these sites
and
out they went and they did a very
natural thing they took my map all very
excited about it and went to every cave
that they didn't know about first
and so they had explored some of these
kids lots of them have been explored by
amateurs and stuff like that you know
the bigger ones and stuff so they went
for all the the new things it's Human
Nature
and so I was getting reports we're now
moving if you imagine sort of June July
August of 2013 they weren't finding much
you know little bits and pieces but
nothing really exciting
then at the last bit they went to a cave
called the rising star cave which is a
very well known cave it's right to paint
the picture of this there are a series
of very famous caves caves like
strokefontaine and sword crowns which
all appear in one Valley that was the
historical place of discovery
ninety percent of the fossil discoveries
of ancient humeral does it occurred in
three sites that are within a kilometer
of each other
the rising star cave is a kilometer from
that right in the middle of this thing
and so everyone's been in it it's used
for training of cavers I've been in it
in the 90s you know there's nothing
there but they were dutifully going
through everything and they went in this
one night September 13th and went
through the cave four and a half hours
reached an area called Dragon's Back
this is this area imagine it's like 120
meters back into a Cave System 30 meters
underground and they crawled up this
Dragon's Back which is a rock collapse
to the top of it and at the very top of
it Steve was trying to take a picture
get a picture of himself and he slid
into this little slot
and his legs went down a hole
and he told Rick it goes and cavers that
means like it doesn't stop
big word I know
and
being young and skinny and insane
down he went
not knowing if it opened up into a big
thing and he dies or whatever if he
could get out
and it goes 12 meters down into a
chamber
and inside that chamber they saw some
bones on the ground
little white specks like those
and you know what they were but they
took pictures of them that picture
and they went out took them forever to
get out they the next couple of days
I've seen at home nine o'clock at night
and my intercom this is Johannesburg
Gates and everything long distance to
your house but intercom goes nine
o'clock at night I answer it and there's
Pedra on the other side he says you're
going to want to let us in creepy like
that
and I almost didn't then I did and
Stephen Pedra come in they opened their
laptop they showed me this picture
and they shall be the next picture
ah there I got one
there I got one
that is a hominid mandible
and immediately I realized that that's
not just any hominid I could tell by the
audience reaction they too realize that
that is a primitive hominid because the
tooth morphology extends to a larger and
larger molar row which I could tell at
least 80 percent of you knew instantly
and I thought oh my goodness no human
being I guarantee you had ever seen an
image like that anywhere on the planet
like I said 22 000 hours to get that
skull out this is laying on the floor
and every picture they showed me had
another one and another one and another
one and they described the situation it
was in
this
130 meters back up this climb and down
the shaft that they happily fed
the shoot-like thing they described was
19 and a half centimeters as its widest
17 centimeters at its narrowest with all
these terrible moments in it and these
guys you know these guys are the size of
paper
and I was like I will never do this
that's it
that's the entrance that's the wide part
look at his helmet folks to get an idea
of that you want to see you want to see
how really bad it is
this yeah here we go
this is what it looks like to get there
this is the easy part folks
is what we call Superman's crawl
and this is where you have to Superman
because you know the flying position
you extend your arm out and you go
oh come on we oh I get through this
uh it's that's not not terrible you go
through this you climb Dragon's Back you
then get to the hard part the shoot area
that that you go it's not that bad folks
it really isn't cheap even in this dark
I can see the claustrophobes like all
going you know looking down at the
ground and well you're making me anxious
right now I need a sedative for an MRI
you want you want you want to be anxious
let's look at what it's like if we can
of what it's like to come through the
Chute I think the next video does that
this makes me anxious this is when I was
a baby I think
you came out feet first
let's explain maybe yeah that's right so
is that now at the end the first chamber
you're in these spaces in these very
narrow spaces and that's what we had to
do so you got to remember I'm seeing
this I get I go through there and I'm
wondering how we're going to do this by
the way in order to test I'd hire these
amateurs to see whether it was real
because you know I'm trusting the entire
reputation of my team if I if I put
together an expedition to do this I
didn't tell you this because right after
Pedro and Steve left I'm all full of
this oh my goodness this is gigantic
Discovery they're lying on the floor 2
A.M in the morning I called the head of
Missions at National Geographic Society
Terry Garcia to him my time it was like
earlier in in the US and even though I
had caller ID he answered the phone and
I showed it I said you knew your
computer I showed him those pictures and
I said if you are ever going to believe
in me believe in me right now
that's Explorer speak for I need money
so yeah and they had funded you in the
past yeah okay
and he paused for a little bit and he
said okay Lee do what you need to do
that's thunder speak for okay he's been
somebody you know don't do too much on
that
I hung up the phone and I got cold feet
because you know I'm just risking I have
this incredible yeah I mean I mean the
I'm living the dream of science you know
I have this incredible team one of the
biggest teams ever assembled for this
all these Prestige papers and all that
and I've just risked the entire
reputation onto amateurs in this sort of
situation a place I will never go but
you saw the photo right was with that
you ever seen Photoshop no seriously
yeah you're worried that could wow
people do funny things huh oh come on
someone just faked a shark picture and
it was a plastic model you saw that from
Greek I mean it'll do anything yeah well
I've seen Bigfoot too you know it's not
so how was I going to test this so I
knew someone I trusted that could fit in
there my then 15 year old very skinny
son Matthew
so I taught him how to use a scientific
camera at scale sent him through went
through with him sent him down
was it was Dad at all concerned about
this did he damage the camera oh man
his mother didn't know
so there I am seen in the dark he's down
30 minutes he comes back up he has a
camera
and you know as his head emerges from
this death-defying thing because I'm
going for father of the year you can all
tell here I didn't go you know are you
okay I went and and he goes he turns
around and said Dad it was so beautiful
my hands were shaking for three minutes
before I could take a picture and he
shows me the back of that and there they
are it's real
so I'd go out that night after coming
out of that terrible thing and I'm like
how am I going to do this I need people
I need people who can climb or skinny
who have degrees and phds and can
excavate precious material
how am I going to find that
and now of course the amateur Community
knows about this right you're worried
I'm worried yeah
they're just lying there I mean you
can't close this off I mean it's a it's
not even on my land you know it's on
someone's land yeah
and so I'm thinking how do you do this
and so I guess I did what anyone would
do
I put a Facebook ad out
you don't have to read that it says I
need skinny scientists
that are willing to drop everything and
come for an expedition they have to have
a PhD or equivalent or be studying for
one they have to have excavation
experience climate experience caving
experience not claustrophobic work well
in teams are willing to work for free
and I'm not going to tell you what
you're going to do and you're going to
risk your life
and I sent that out and I thought you
know there are three or four people in
the world might qualify for that I got
57 qualified applicants
of which I selected six of them who were
the most qualified who just happened to
be young women
and they were extraordinary
um and we launched what was called the
rising star Expedition after the cave
itself to get these things I designed
this whole system this nasa-like system
you know with a command center and three
and a half kilometers of cables with
security cameras and all that doing it
and we started this Expedition and I
also decided by the way to live stream
it to the whole world
had a million followers by the end of
this Expedition
day two we knew I was wrong it wasn't a
hominid skeleton
it was more than one hominid skeleton
we had three right femurs
by the end of the week
we had brought up from underground in
these extreme circumstances
more hominid fossils that had been found
at the richest site in the world to that
date certain decades which was a
kilometer away one week it taken 90
years to get that strokefontaine
by the end of an expedition at three and
a half weeks we discovered the richest
series of hominid discoveries in all of
history
in the middle of it we were just
everyone knew this was like
it was like a moon moment you know you
can see the emotion I think on the faces
we were just in awe of this moment that
we were in that Discovery was happening
and you know this was like scientific
Nirvana you know it's uh and you'll see
the kind of conditions they were working
in you know deep underground the this is
what they were doing in these spaces
they were incredible they were heroiced
I at one time during an interview in
that period I said
you know I'm looking at these I'm seeing
them on these images they're like
astronauts they're so remote from us
when this happens they're like
underground astronauts boy I wish I'd
never said that because I've got hate
mail from around the world because I
know it should be troglenauts or you
know spelionauts or whatever but I said
it and it caught on and then I got in
trouble for it but it stuck
and and you know you can see how big
they are by the way look at Becca here
um this is the kind of size of people
that get into these spaces yeah how do
they carry the bones out in a little
tiny bags inside of this really we had
this hugely complex development that I'd
done of Tupperware that you closed and
put the thing in in foil and then in
toilet paper inside Tupperware inside a
waterproof bag and hand carried out in a
sort of chain
uh we would go I the lab suddenly got
busy and scientists started flying in
from all over the world I think you can
see a picture of the lab that we we
constructed coming up there we would
work all day people were all these
scientists were right it was so cool it
was live signs happening in the middle
of the world we were working late into
the night I mean you know you there's
some images I think of us in night in
there and you know all this time we're
watching these images of them on the
screen going back and forth back and
forth they're working for hours and
hours and hours and it was unbelievable
these are the kind of images we saw I
mean this is this is incredible these
you see these images of that's the kind
of thing that you're watching I would
spend the next seven years staring at
images like this this place
um
I just want the audience to know that I
am an equal opportunity child abuser
that's my daughter Megan who's in the
audience today somewhere they're here
she's University of Queensland vet
school right there
that's a position called Shoot troll
um she's up at the top there and her job
was to go up and down the Chute I used
her to test the safety equipment before
I sent the ass time I was in I didn't
tell her mother that either
uh look I'm sending other people's
children and I need to be able to risk
my own and I'm serious about that I I
was taking other people's kids into the
extreme spaces into that expedition it
was extraordinary and you know from this
little chamber deep underground
a tiny space that's sort of 10 meters
long by five meters wide we discovered
over 1 500 individual fossils from a one
meter by 50 centimeter excavation the
richest single put that in perspective
folks to that point in history in
sub-equatorial Africa there'd probably
been 1100 individual fossils found about
80 percent isolated teeth
huh three weeks
and there was clearly more of them in
there and could you tell how many
individuals were after we started
looking at these fossils you know we had
skulls we had actual schools and skulls
are rare you know we had that one from
there we had skulls like this you know
and we had slightly bigger ones and
little ones it was clear they were
really weird from it we had dentition we
had you know dozens and dozens of teeth
we had foot bones that were just
completely our things this like this you
know you should go off for this because
paleontologists around the world went
holy cow these are not the kind of
things we see in the fossil record you
know the Primitive hominin fossil record
we had we had hands that were actually
sitting articulated
just like that one just like that
it was
unbelievable and and stupidly odd we
knew that as we were looking and you
were looking at a thing that was
different at the end of it we had this
just assemblage you could lay out just
dozens and dozens and dozens and dozens
1500 fossils for 15 plus individuals
it was unbelievable
and then I got to play science in terms
of interpreting what the heck this is
absolutely and I got to play science in
a way that was really really nasty I
said you know there was a thing in our
field about you had to have experience
to study ancient hominid fossils and
there was even someone who said that if
you haven't studied one before you
shouldn't be allowed to study another
one
that's the Shaker kind of mentality of
of of you know science where eventually
you all die out and everyone just looks
at the things I guess
um and so I I pick particularly young
people from across the very best and
brightest hugely diverse
and brought them together as a gigantic
team to study these and we had the time
of our lives the Only Rule was
they had to they had to release all of
their data sets to the team so we shared
data and made it open access across the
field
and then we named a new species
and started finding more of them not
just in that chamber but in other
Chambers nearby we found a skeleton
from a chamber 100 meters away that was
in an Alcove up on the wall
a beautiful thing
maybe one of the bigger individuals we
found it had a beautiful skull I mean
just almost the complete thing that you
could look at you can actually see this
face of this tiny brained hominid
a hominid that had a brain about a third
the size of a human
it was clearly primitive there's one you
can see it they had they had this kind
of rounded crating kind of like a human
but that these brow ridges that you can
see there that flattened face that would
prognatic that is the nose stuck out the
teeth were small but primitive like I
saw in that first mandible
but that's where most studies in our
field would have ended but we had these
bodies
everything from neonates to the elderly
and so we could begin to construct the
whole anatomy and what we saw was this
bizarre Mosaic creature you know it had
it had shoulders like an ape it had a
spine like a mini Neanderthal a pelvis
like a hominid that was three or four
million years old like Lucy's pelvis but
then as you move down the limbs towards
the the feet and the hands
they became more and more advanced until
you reach these hands that while they
were curved they were almost super
human-like with really long thumbs
and the feet as you got to them the long
skinny legs and they became almost
human-like except for having slightly
curved toes it was like this mishmash
of every species that we'd found from
like three million years old
to say a million years old
we would put it all together
and we could look at this creature you
could actually see its physical body
effectively and reconstruct it and
compare it to other hominids and so you
got this visual reconstruction of a of
of this living creature standing next to
all these other homes now if you just
say had the feet you would have
reconstructed a different looking
creature who is it human
huh if it had hands we would have said
funny human with a long thumb
if we'd had the teeth
we would have said
maybe it's a mini robust
australopithecine or primitive
australopithesia if we'd had the face we
would have said oh that's that's an
australopitheism if we had the head
Cranium we would said Homo habilis
maybe a bit of homo erectus thrown in
there if I had the spine where you said
funky Neanderthal but there are no
neanderthals in Africa so we had the
shoulders I might have said Gibbon
and so we did what scientists do time
and again we named a new species homo
naletti we put it in the genus homo
because of that head
and because we felt the overall grade
adaptation was to bipedalism and living
on the ground that this was in our ilk
more so than australopi but we debated
it a long time it hovered there
on the edge of both sides depending on
what part you looked at you know we
could build it this is one John Gertz
he's a great reconstructions we could
build this whole image of this guy
and that was so exciting because
maybe the audience people in the
audience I bet some of them realize that
we didn't get to do this with certainty
before this moment almost every other
Discovery you've ever heard about in
this field is built from scraps and
often built from scraps that we are not
a hundred percent sure belong to the
same thing
and with the exception of perhaps I'd
argue Neanderthals
we just don't have a highly diverse
record of young and old and so the
ability to build an image of one of
these and then lots of them at different
age groups and the ability to understand
them was was
truly unknown at that time I mean you
know Australopithecus sediva and malapa
had been extraordinary but it wasn't
this
this was that on steroids
and we were sitting there with this
knowledge that something weird was going
on and here's what that weird thing was
by the end of the first week as we were
sitting there in this Command Center
imagine everyone and you saw the emotion
on everyone's face which is like I had
to buy there was a joke going around
during the expedition of you know we're
gonna need a bigger Vault you know
remember that scene in Jaws where the
shark comes up and goes we're going to
need a bigger boat
we need a bigger safe because we brought
these safes out to keep the you know the
five pieces we were certain we were
going to find we had 400 by the end of
the the thing and
but what I didn't kind of highlight was
we had only hominids
only hominids
from those deep Chambers nothing else
was coming out just
these fossil human relatives I remember
very poignantly at the end of the first
week you know this all happened to us
at the end of the day these filthy
underground astronauts come out one of
Marina had brought out the last bit and
I look at it and it's all hominy and I
said are you guys cheating
are you actually picking up only the you
know and leaving the you know the
animals behind and they went nope
we're taking them as they come
and over beers that night with a couple
of scientists I remember this really
powerful moment
that was occurring because you know all
of us a lot of us had trained in lots of
things I was a geologist an
archaeologist and part of being an
archaeologist you train is sore forensic
anthropology
and
one of the things you learn as a
forensic anthropologist when you're
studying natural occurrences
whether they're collected by carnivores
or catastrophe they're always mixed you
get animals and everything and in fact
in the hominid record it's like
99.9 animals 0.1 hominins
we had never seen a situation that was
all
hominins
well we actually had
but not in the ancient fossil record
we see it all the time in human
assemblages
the reason we see it all the time in
human assembly is because humans
sort themselves after death from the
natural world
and we have
places that we put ourselves
mostly separate you know sometimes we
put our dead poodles with us or if
you're a pharaoh you're dead cats and
Falcons but mostly we put up ourselves
with each other or alone
and so it was becoming pretty clear even
by week two
there must be another explanation and so
when we published this new species
in 2015. in the journal E-Life you'll
remember that
we said something incredibly
controversial
we said that the only possible reason
that there could be only hominids in
this deep dark remote chamber
is that they put themselves there
they must have gone through some sort of
ritualized behavior of carrying their
dead
into these
spaces and I'll tell you before it's in
your mind know the spaces haven't
changed that much no other entrance no
other entrances they're going into this
extraordinary space
the way we do
and they're taking their debt in there
and they're disposing of them
in a ritualized manner I want to be
careful there because ritual means
different things to different people I
was very careful of saying ritual means
repeated
because
while the world accepted our new species
very readily
because we had so much
to say that a tiny brain hominid was
actually disposing of its dead
in a ritualized manner in a place like
this
that was received and so you ever heard
the saying of you know received it
floated like a lead balloon
that was kind of how the reception was
because
those type of Mortuary behaviors are
related to a big brain
we claim it as ours
it is a human thing it's done by humans
it's done because our big brain and the
way we are and it only happens 60 70 000
years ago in our lineage maybe a little
earlier
and even the cases where people say it
may have occurred in the other large
Brain thing neanderthals the few cases
where they think there may be burial
that took Decades of fighting to even be
remotely thing we were stepping into the
definition of Human by the way did you
know there's no definition of human
brine
if you ask me to be I'd be hard-pressed
to give you a definition so I can well
remember so is Webster's Dictionary and
every other side probably just kind of
circular right it's like humans are
people who are kind of like humans or
something like that
he's not joking look it up look at
Google Google the definition of a human
it'll say having the characteristic of
people or a person
if you look up homo sapiens it'll say
having the characteristic of a human
um you know why because we don't have an
out group
right everything's like us that does
like us and we see ourselves as totally
human exceptionalism but can I ask you I
mean just to play Devil's advociversity
I mean you know obviously I know you
fielded a thousand variations on the
following theme but one at least can
imagine other
explanations I mean the one that comes
to mind for me which I'm sure you can
shoot down is what if everybody went
into the cave alive and the ones you
found are the ones that couldn't get
back out yeah great
um like like people like me had gone
[Laughter]
extra later
um
the answer is that we threw one of the
largest scientific teams in history at
this problem we did not say it lightly
and we eventually like Sherlock Holmes
had worked our way through we could
prove they weren't washed in there we
could prove that they had come in over
time
somewhere earlier somewhere later
they had come in whole we can see that
as bodies
they were violating gravity and all that
they had it wasn't a catastrophic event
it wasn't some movement of water there
were no evidence of carnivores there or
Scavenging or any marks on their bodies
and eventually after that and lots of
other evidence
we had eliminated all the probable
and we were left with the improbable
that we had discovered the first time in
history
that a non-human species and something
that clearly is outside of our grade
that was practicing some sort of
deliberate moratorium
that remains controversial
I'm hoping not for long
but it remains controversial today and
what really made it tough
was with this tiny brain hominid that by
then people were had rapidly began
telling us we didn't have a date for it
we couldn't tell you how old it was
now that's a problem in pale of
anthropology
because everyone thinks dates wrongly by
the way
are super important for saying where
something fits because everyone thinks
Evolution works like a biblical story of
you know in austro afferences begets
Homo habilis begets Homo erectus but it
doesn't happen that way species can
arise as a fission or breakout and the
others can continue quite happily that's
why we can see coelacans today you know
just keep on going they keep on going
and so it's much more complex but humans
have always seen themselves as so
exceptional that we have this sort of
image that once the next better
mousetrap evolves nothing can so we had
scientists that were saying that the
morphology of noleti
was showing that it was really probably
just some kind of primitive Homo erectus
it must be when they say that they mean
2 million 2.2 2.3 million years old or
it's a another species of primitive homo
or it's even a late australopi but all
of them were you know a million and a
half two and a half million years old
you could look at its Anatomy
but we threw the kitchen sink beginning
a date because no one had ever you gotta
remember you gotta be sympathetic with
us no one had ever found a whole bunch
of hominids lying on the floor in a dirt
cave and then immediately beneath the
floor we didn't have technology we
invented it
um with by the way quite a lot of
Australian researchers some from
Griffith University here and others with
your great facilities here
and we broke through the day yes indeed
that does deserve a round of the thought
thank you Australian research committee
and Australian government and do it
again
um
and
we broke through we invented new ways we
refined new ways to come to these
answers and then we announced how old
they were and the answer is
Young
incredibly Young
so young that it was unbelievable in
fact there you see their tiny little
brain
at 230 000 to 330 000 years ago more
than a million and a half plus years is
what they should have been by their
looks
right in the middle of Africa
at the time when only Homo sapiens
should have been there at the exact
moment when we thought
that modern human mind was arising from
all the archeology that was appearing
we were seeing the development of more
complex archeology coming along
and
that
blew everyone away and how confident are
you of those dates I am confident that
some of them
are that old
which is all you need really to make the
point yes
my hesitancy in your answer is that
we've obviously been continuing the
research
and I suspect
that things are going to change
um I think that we have encountered
something extraordinary the idea that if
a small brain to primitive hominy and by
the way that does it doesn't mean our
colleagues are wrong
that homo naledi doesn't exist in a
million a million and a half two million
years remember the coelacanth example
that I gave
what it means is these groups of them at
least some of them aren't that age right
but it means they existed back then
it also means they could come forward in
time we're not witnessing an Extinction
event
so I think there's going to be big news
in the future about
the range the time range and you know
just because you have to be talking to
someone who kind of maybe knows that
there are going to be alterations in
that and this is one
cave area right you have many other
sizes potentially
um we have yet to find definitively
hormonality elsewhere but I would
caution you if you go back to that brief
Anatomy lesson I was talking about
it'd be hard to see something like this
if you didn't have the whole picture
and it would be easy to take bits and
pieces
and mix it into other things that we had
and not see the whole particularly in a
record that has been as sparse
as as as we have when you look at this
Mosaic Anatomy
we are on the edge of just incredible
things Brian I mean it is we've been at
this I by the way I didn't stop
exploring we have made other discoveries
in other places I learned my lesson from
gladysville and learned my lesson from
sediba I learned my lesson from this I
didn't stop exploring during covid we
discovered 250 meters away from the site
and entirely another giant site full of
hominid fossils but not these fossils
something different
and that was really cool too because
coven was great for us
don't don't hate
it knocked me off my pedestal of success
it took me out of this rut of you know
here I was I built this gigantic
organization
that was based on scientists we make a
discovery scientist fly in from all over
the world they work with it that they
Mentor all my young scientists in Africa
we get the papers out we'd scribe them
off we go my teams are working in
confined humid spaces underground where
if they get stuck we have to send in
other people to rescue them and we're
all working in you know we even our
preparation within these rooms together
that are likely properly poorly
ventilated but don't say that and you
know and then a pandemic comes along
and I went from hero to zero in minutes
you know South Africa did not have an
easy lockdown I know you didn't too but
ours ours is worse than yours
um and so I had to start up
and it made me redesign it and I had to
figure out how to excavate a site and so
I did and and I'm reading I couldn't
work underground so I took the
underground and brought it above ground
watch the Youtube videos it's really
funny and and it also made me realize
that I'd made a mistake with with my
idea that bringing in the best and
brightest scientists all the time was a
way of mentoring the young African
scientists who were coming up what it
also was doing was they could do it
better and faster so it was a form of
mentoring but it also meant there was
always someone right above you that you
couldn't be through so I'm standing here
with this discovery that we made in the
middle of covert we brought the cave up
and there they were you know these new
type hominids
and I had all these young people around
me and I said you know what I haven't
done is I haven't given them the
leadership on this so I did
and you know how what they did they did
great you know they just turned on the
afterburners
all right so you're watching all these
wonderful discoveries taking place but
you're close but one step removed
watching it in a television monitor
computer screen
you must have wanted to go down right to
be part of it you know I used to cover
up that desire you know from the moment
that Stephen Pedro showed me those
images and described the situation and
when I crawled up there and sent Matthew
down and was staring down into that void
I knew I'd never fit into this space I
used to joke that you know my ego was
too large to actually fit into that that
that shoot area and a lot of that was a
way of covering up that I just couldn't
do it you know with people that were
going in are fit they're smaller than me
and
things began to change is over the years
I was watching this and you know I'm
watching it through these video screens
I'm remote from it but
just before coven
we made a discovery and that Discovery
was sort of shocking I think to all of
us I was in the command center
Canoe moliopane one of my mentees was
sitting next to me and we were watching
the underground astronauts Excavating
and they had moved the camera that day
so it sat up above them behind them over
their shoulder it normally sat on the
side so I could be monitoring where
their hands were saying oh you know hold
on that looks like a mandible this looks
like stop or
and they moved it because it was in the
way of the excavation
and it was an infrared camera
and a weird thing happened because as
they would shift occasionally they would
block the light that was adjacent to
them that we were shining on it and it
would shift infrared
and in a moment I've seen they're
staring into this excavation you gotta
remember that's happening for days and
days and days of the tedium you know
you're like a NASA watching a space
flight occur where you can never touch
it right and I saw the shift and I
realized that there was an edge to what
they were digging I could see a physical
feature
and I turned to Kenny and I said you
know you see that and she looked at it
and I said this is a line This is a
feature
and I suddenly realized something that
maybe been sitting in the back of my
mind and some of our scientists through
this remarkable thing where we're
looking at this assemblage the world's
largest assemblage of hominid it's
coming from these tiny areas
we'd always been terrified to say the
words burial
I'd been as you know I'd been super
careful over the years to say ritual
disposal of the debt because we're
dealing with a hominid with a brain
slightly larger than chimpanzee burial
Graves that's a human thing in fact if
you had to talk about something that
almost defines a big brain human
behavior that's the the thing you know
that's our well it's one of the things
and the earliest known ones to that
point were like a hundred thousand years
at most 78
000 to 85 000 you know it's young yeah
sure and Neanderthal is younger than
that
and controversial and I'm staring at I
realized it's this is hole in the ground
they've been digging a hole in the
ground with a curled up body in it one
body
in a fetal position
and sudden I could see it
from a trick of a light
and I told him to stop oh boy they were
not happy I will tell you that they were
you know because they're right here
they they are and this is a terrible
place you know you you're risking your
life every time you go in
well
we do the science we do the excavations
we would find out
it was a burial it was a grave I'm on
the lady went in and dug holes put whole
bodies in them in a flexed position
like a fetal position you can actually
see the remnants of the Holy See the
remnants of the hole they dug even to
where the dirt clods are tossed out of
it then they put those bags on Wow and
you suddenly find out
all the Mysteries why we were getting
these dense bodies the first excavation
we uh we worked in back in 2013 you know
where we recovered that incredible
assemblage of of hominid parts from one
meter by 50 centimeters you know why it
was four or five overlapping Graves like
a medieval symmetry where they dug
through didn't know the body was there
toss them together and put them back
it explained the articulated remains it
explained why there were vertical bones
because the bodies had been sitting up
and had collapsed on themselves the
material we saw on the surface was stuff
that had dribbled out as the mound of
dirt settled below the body then we
found the same thing in the hill
anti-chamber
we found children
four of them in one hole
one little 13-ish year old body curled
up the whole body
two faces just the faces of children
and a fetus
in one hole
in a slope
and nothing else no grave Goods or
anything well funny you should ask
because when we scan this we actually
took it out in a plaster jacket hole
which was no mean feat you've heard the
description of this thing it had to fit
through 17 and a half centimeters so we
had to get this thing up it weighed
probably 70 kilos you can imagine
getting up that 12 meters
when we scanned it with CT scan
one rock in this whole thing
you can see the base of the Grave you
see where they dug into it
and that rock is sitting in the hand
the child
that's curled into a fetal position
and it's shaped like a tool
now no human being has ever touched that
to this moment it's still in that
plaster jacket oh is it we've
synchrotroned it we have it at 30
microns
in this paper we just published there's
we've been very cautious that calling it
a tool shaped Rock
but I'm not much of a betting guy
I'm a scientist but I'll tell you it
shouldn't be there there's no other
rocks like that and it's shaped exactly
like
the first tool with art on it from
blumbass cave at 78 000 years done by
Homo sapiens shaped identical it looks
like a kind of Engraving tool and is it
but it's in the child's literally
sitting in the child's hand
is it or isn't it
it's probably going to be argued for the
next
either hundred years
or the next few months until we find
another one that's right yeah right but
so you started this with getting down
there
at the beginning of last year
I
I'm turning 57 now here you know 2022.
spring chicken yeah not so much not for
caving
and I was staring at these papers that
we were preparing and this is a big deal
I think this is the biggest Discovery I
will make in my entire career I mean
we're about to describe a non-human
species that buries its dead potentially
hundreds of thousands of years before
humans invent that
that's a big deal yeah and I think it is
the biggest deal as we're writing this
paper which I think is probably going to
be the biggest paper that I will
participate in in my entire life
all these contradictions begin to appear
ideas of geology geological problems it
didn't make sense you know that we had
still a geologists or two were saying no
well there's some there's some lateral
flow or movement of material maybe
Waters involved and yet all the geology
all the thin sections say that's not
true there were there were problems with
the way that that we were describing the
relationship between the two burial
Chambers the hill chamber in the
denality chamber and and there were a
bunch of little sort of minor things but
I'm sitting here thinking I cannot
put out this gigantic discovery that is
literally going to affect archeology and
pale anthropology forever
if we don't have everything
and so I started looking at myself
I'd of course like everyone put a little
bit of covered kilos on
and uh and I've always been a big guy
and I'm tall and
so in February I was I realized that we
were going to have Expeditions in the
middle of the year into this area I
wanted to excavate in the chamber
adjacent to the burial Chambers dragons
back where we kid up and get ready to
climb and go down you've seen those
images just now
and so I started losing weight my wife
and daughter were like saying oh we got
covered kilos I just was quiet I didn't
tell anyone I started losing weight by
just eating less eating less eating high
protein smaller portions starting to
work out a lot
and lost 25 kilos 25 25 kilos so chunk
of weight 50. 32 in wait I've been that
since I was in the Navy and
and
coming up on the Expedition uh in in
July
we started the day we started the
expedition
canalway was going to be leading the
team Excavating in the Dragon's Back
chamber I climbed up we had a
documentary crew filming I said time and
I climbed up dragon's back with some
colleagues that flown out for this this
this work from the U.S and I got to the
top then at the back of dragon's back
where the Chute is and I took them up
there showed them that they'd never seen
it they go down as they hook harnesses
and go down this really this hard climb
and I stayed and I slid back into that
space
and it did something I'd never done
before I
slid into this
shoot thinking you were going to go down
or not checking it out right there not
right there you would
too un you do not go down low yeah I
don't think you just freelance but I
slid into it and dropped myself in got
my pelvis back and waist and then stared
down into the abyss wow I said I can
make this
I came out had the days in brief and I
said I'm going to make this attempt
tomorrow you should have seen the faces
of my explorers they were not uh
thrilled I think but they some of them
were like you can do this others were
like you know you could see the
and so the next morning did you have
caving experience I've been for you know
for decades okay you know I'm so it
wasn't a matter of it's not experience
I would be by far the largest person
that's gone in both in physical
dimensions and height yeah
only 47 humans had ever been in that
space
and because of the danger and the
difficulty and so the next morning
I made the attempt
and gone in and from the moment I got in
I knew this was the hardest thing I'd
ever do in my life I mean it was it was
terrible
I mean it was it's not a shoot I don't
know how we've described it like that
that tells you it's a vertical
chimney-like thing it's not it's a
labyrinth and you're moving actually
laterally almost five meters As you move
down this and that's a long way when
you're moving through spaces that you
can't even turn your head nor see your
feet
and that's before you get to the 17 and
a half inch squeeze which is about
halfway down six meters or so down
and I got to that and I pushed into it
and realized that I had to make a
decision because
it's not going down
you got to come up too yeah going down
you have gravity and I hit my chest and
realize that if I push this next thing I
might not be able to get out of this and
we can't I answer all those questions no
we can't modify it it's a Labyrinth of
of of of chert layers and stuff and this
is gigantic ancient Dolomite you break
the wrong stick on this that whole thing
can come down not only destroying the
fossil situation but killing you in the
process and anyone else near you it
doesn't collapse in little bits
and so I pushed in and went on in now
that was emotional everything if I get
in finally and it was hard and I'm
sitting in the hill anti-chamber
standing there
and I'm very emotional
you know you haven't been able to
breathe properly so I'm hyperventilating
kind of thing properly because I didn't
think I'd ever be in there and I an
identify anything which you'd appreciate
I decided I was not going to take a
picture
because I've been watching this place
digitally
for almost well
three quarters of a decade
I want to narrate so I took a narration
out and I started talking describing
everything at a measuring device and
talking and describing everything and I
start describing these and I immediately
start seeing things we missed like
simple things that don't mean a lot to
people right now but the dirt wasn't
coming out of the shoot and we've
actually written that I don't know how
we quite missed it but it's coming out
of another passage so the dirt that's in
the chamber is coming from the interior
of the cave no one was throwing bodies
into this it didn't come they don't the
dirt's not coming from where we're
coming in we're just coming in the way
we can fit
says there's another
well there's internal entrances that
don't go anywhere I see okay then I
noticed that flowstones on the ground
had been broken
but not by us in the Deep past
and moved uphill place
had broken them to get to the dirt
underneath to bury the bodies underneath
because flat plates don't move uphill
yeah and these are little things that
people have been in there but only like
three geologists have ever been in there
people quit noticing these things you
know it's backyard syndrome you and I
have talked about that before the idea
that you quit seeing places you're
familiar with particularly places that
are hard to get to you've almost died
getting there and you're worried about
getting out and you're there to do a job
and then I get to the edge of the
chamber and there's this passage that
leads from the hill burial chamber to
the dinality chamber where the big
burial places are
and it wasn't like what I I'd imagine
seeing on images when you're there it's
totally different it's a doorway and I
say this you know I say it's smaller
than I thought it looks like a doorway
and I'm I'm an archaeologist
I see doorways what do you see above
doorways let me see there's a doorway
what's above it the exit sign yeah a
sign yeah
and I looked at it
and looked to the left
and actually couldn't believe what I saw
there on the left hand side
we're carvings
Engravings
symbols
first thing I saw as a cross went up
right side up went upside down
a box a square and you saw triangles
I saw a fish-shaped image
I mean I don't know if it is a fish or
not it's a it's a non-geometric image
ladders
it's incredible all etched into this 2.9
billion year old rock
and people had just walked by them isn't
that insane I mean I know I I gather the
back here I get it but
I mean you have trained team the world's
great you know wouldn't someone I did it
surprise you
it you know I thought a lot about that
obviously because you know I go to them
I look at them I almost had a
Transcendent experience it was really
weird and I'm often embarrassed to even
talk about it like this but
I know why it happens physiologically
but that material I looked at them and
they actually floated off it when I
turned on a black light onto them they
floated in space you know kind of like
Queen's Gambit sort of stuff that you
see a beautiful mind and I know why it
happened it's a light shift phenomena
you would understand that it's what
happens when you see car lights at night
as they move in the opposite direction
you know why your brain does it but yeah
it's still very weird yeah
um I was probably close to a trance
stated you could probably get you know
from exhaustion and fear and all that
kind of thing but
um
I think that
Pathfinder syndrome had sort of built in
it's a dangerous place the first people
in are risking their lives everyone's
preaching get back alive
you know that's the thing that's why
some few people live and you become very
Mission focused we were there to dig
almost always we were digging in those
far Chambers by the time the third
fourth or fifth person has gone in
everyone gets the Explorer mindset which
is so dangerous
smart just what you said smart people
have been here that they've seen
everything that's here that's not my job
my job is in there I think that's what
happened and I'm there with a different
mindset one to solve problems and two I
know for damn sure I will never be back
in this space this is my shot this is my
first and last time to be in here right
anyway I describe them I am blown away I
can't believe it I'm looking at
Engravings and I know no humans have
been in here other than us these aren't
us and I could see there were layers
they'd actually erased older images with
dirt from the ground and then carved
through them again maybe to highlight
them we see that in Upper Paleolithic
images all the time and these images I
knew looked like the things we've seen
you know neanderthals doing we see well
not so much that but humans doing yeah
you know the earliest Engravings these
geometric forms it looks like the
earliest art
anyway I go through I go through the
whole cave over the next three hours or
so I discovered soot on the ceiling that
we hadn't seen you know our explorers
hadn't been looking up fire was in there
and it was right in front of our eyes
because in earlier accounts remember it
was saying there's no evidence no
evidence and you yeah when we you and I
talked about this you know fire is hard
to see in a couple of minutes we talked
ourselves out of the obvious scientists
are human too folks
they're human too
and you know you these things happen all
the time there are thousands scientific
discovery stories just like this aren't
there yeah where something someone
suddenly sees something right in front
of everyone else
and I finish and I'm coming back down
this passage and I decided to do a funny
thing
I'm coming out I'm all I'm thinking
about is I've got to survive this climb
out
and
then I say you know what this is my last
chance in here I want to be the height
of naletti and so I got down on my knees
In this passage and started crawling and
I got back in just opposite
the back of that those images carved on
the left hand side of the door so now
it's the right hand side of the best
I see this gigantic
cross hatch type hashtag
crosses
I mean gigantic right there
as bright as that exit son
you know I'd even walk by it on the way
in and there it was
carved deep into this over an algal
stromatolite billions of years old and
then done multiple times so somebody
worked hard and multiple multiple times
you know I discovered the earliest
symbols ever create first time humans
have recognized
symbols created by a non-human species
with a brain slightly larger than a
chimpanzees we've we've seen that
something
I mean none of us
as you know burials are one thing
meaning making symbols carved into the
wall above those burials and in the
passages by we thought that
that's us
it's not us
and it's hundreds of thousands of years
before us thinks about that now one
question immediately comes to mind I'm
sure it's been thrown at you a thousand
times but
at what point do you think you're
reading more
into it like could it just be like the
Mindless Doodles of the unconscious mind
just you know they're down there and I'm
not reading anything to it I hadn't said
the word art yeah I haven't said the
word I said they're meaning making
symbols
even an unconscious doodle is a meaning
making symbol right
nothing does that nothing on the planet
that we're aware of
has ever done that
other than large brained
humans
and possibly neanderthals which are
large Brain humans and how do you
distinguish it from other things that
are granted are different but like Bower
Birds when they make their their nest to
try to try where they make a elaborate
design that's a radically different kind
of radically different kind of thing
that's a that's a a sort of it's I
believe that I think I think we may as
humans be in a moment where we're about
to lose our specialness human
special nature the idea of human
exceptionalism maybe just died
I don't know if that's that different I
know we made it different
but homo naledi just proved us
that another species with a brain that's
not our brain and much smaller but
smaller but incredibly smaller yeah
accomplished
effectively the entire cultural package
that probably was used moments before
the definition of what it means to be
human
it's an absolutely remarkable story and
it is something that we will all be
looking forward to and you know thanks
enormously for all you're doing to
clarify where we all came from thanks
Brian and thank you guys by the way I
love Brisbane
oh my goodness
[Applause]
I'll get in trouble for this on YouTube
but it's like Miami without
Miami Miami
[Laughter]
thank you he said that I'm gonna say it
too
um and and secondly I just want to say
one thing I hope what you get from this
because I really want to inspire you
know I speak to kids all over the world
and part of what the thing is is often
they're depressed about the idea that
they won't be they don't know how
they're going to contribute young
scientists how they're told that all the
great discoveries have been made that if
you're moving in you're just standing on
the shoulders of giants and one of the
reason I want to tell my whole story
and I hope you see that that's just not
true
we haven't touched
discovery
we are at the front edge and I'm a field
that thought it was over 20 years ago
there was nothing left to find and if it
can happen in a field like this what
must it be in every other I know you are
a believer in this but we are at a
moment I
assure you the greatest stage of
exploration was not when guys went out
on ships and and introduced themselves
to a place that was already found like
Australia
okay
it's right now absolutely this is the
greatest age of exploration
this is an age where you are all
Explorers with us
that we have technology we can ask
questions and Brilliant Minds can invent
it if not someone who you will invent it
and give it to us and share it you have
all of Humanity's knowledge
in a phone in your pocket
and there's stuff to find folks
just never stop exploring so please join
me in thanking a great Explorer in the
great Age of Exploration thank you man
dancing thank you thank you thank you
thank you everyone thank you
[Music]
thank you